el segundo mayor banco de Suiza anunció
Hace unas horas ese acuerdo para evitar
juicios penales en su contra por
captación ilegal de clientes y
operaciones de blanqueo agravado de
fraude fiscal entre 2005 y 2012 la suma
en cuestión esos 238 millones de euros
incluyen multas de restitución de
beneficios e indemnización por daños y
perjuicios al Estado francés y Apagar
casi de inmediato en tres cuotas y en
nomas de un año Eso sí credi swiss
aclara que la transacción no implica una
admisión de responsabilidad penal y que
en el pasado había puesto fin al secreto
bancario en Europa pero las
investigaciones revelaron que ese banco
creó estructuras para ayudar a sus
clientes a esconder sus activos de la
Administración gala de ese sistema de
evasión fiscal se beneficiaron cerca de
5000 clientes con residencia fiscal aquí
hablamos de activos valorados en nada
menos que 2000 millones de euros se
podría señalar también Suiza es
reincidente en ese tipo de prácticas si
consideramos que en 2017 un afiliar
Suiza del Bronco del banco británico
HSBC tuvo que desembolsar 300 millones
de euros para escapar a un juicio
similar aquí por blanqueo de fraude
fiscal y Que pagó más de 2.000 millones
de dólares a la justicia estadounidense
en un caso similar